[音楽]
[笑い]
こんにちははじめしちです皆さんついに来
ましたHIKAKINさんの
新居20億円ハウス
ですさんついに来ましたHIKAKIN
さんが最近住まれている20億円の豪邸
つきました見てくたさもうすごいのよ大き
さ
がえぐいねガラス張りとかやばいんだよ
大きさがもうこれねすごいねもうめっちゃ
行きたかったんですけどなかなか
タイミングがこうなくてようやく
HIKAKINさんの20億円の合手に
来れたわけなんですけれども今ですね
HIKAKINさんちょっと撮影中でで
もう少ししてから来るんですけれども僕
だけHIKAKINさんのマネージャー
さんに相談して先にHIKAKINさんの
お家に入れていただいたんですけれど
もなんではさん待ってくださいなんで
HIKAKINさんと一緒に来ないんです
かなんでですかて思った方いらっしゃると
思うんですけれど
も俺はただでこの家に来たわけじゃねえ
カキさんね今幸せの絶好調なんですよ結婚
もなされてこんな素敵な家にも住んでさ
なんか親高校されてた気がするんだよな
もういいことだらけすぎてHIKAKIN
さん
[音楽]
がHIKAKINさんの割先いいこと
だらけすぎて俺はちょっと許せねえ
HIKAKINさん
ねあなた最近いいことだらけすぎなんです
よ俺はね人の幸せ幸福が大嫌い人の人生
っていうのやっぱバランスが大事なんです
よ幸せなこともあったりこれ悪いことも
あって人生だと思うので俺がそんな
HIKAKINさんの幸せに収支婦を打つ
今日なんとHIKAKINさんの2億円の
お家に来る時に俺1人で来てません
HIKAKINさんのアンチをネットで
募集して集めて一緒に来まし
たではお呼びしましょうお願いし
[音楽]
ますはいえhikさんのアンチの皆さん
ですよろしくお願いし
ます皆さんはHIKAKINさんのことは
嫌いですかそうですね嫌い
ですなんで大丈夫か今日えちなみにどう
いうところが嫌いですかブブ言ってるだけ
[音楽]
で君は中学高校生であそうですね中うわ
中学生のあんちゃも珍しいというかね子供
に人気なイメージありますけど別に
そんなあんまり好きじゃない俺は好きじゃ
ないですあそっか個人の10だもんね
好き嫌いは学校だとどうですですかさん
はこだと他のやらがHIKAKINさん
すごいよね思んです
けどあますごいとは思わないなるほど
なるほどあえっと大学生やっぱどう思い
ますかうん
も
ああなるほどですね何されてるどうですか
やっぱそのさんあんままYouTubeと
か見ないあなるほどなるほど体そのキさん
の動画見
[音楽]
て開催員の方ですはいYouTubeとか
見られますかいもう見ますよああ見るけど
そのYouTuberにねまひさんも本当
聞きたいのはうん何使ってんだろうねあ稼
あお金とかああなるほどなるほどそのねわ
ないなるほどですね皆さんヒキさんのこと
は嫌いといういうことでそうですね嫌い
嫌いか今こんなちょっとHIKAKIN
さんのことが嫌いで嫌いでたまらないアズ
の人を集めてですねもうすぐ
HIKAKINさんうちに来るんですけど
も初め社長がHIKAKINさんの二条の
お家に行ってルームツアーお部屋の紹介を
してもらうと思うんですけれどもアンチの
皆さんにHIKAKINさんのお家の中に
隠れててもらいます皆さんどうですか
カキンさんの二の豪邸です無駄遣いした
なって感じです皆さん気持ちは分かります
けどもね住所とかも言っちゃだめですよガ
ネットに変えたりとか考えておきますあ
助かりますヒカキさんと俺がルームツアー
で家の中見てる時になんかいろんな場所に
皆さん隠れてくださいこの家の中の隠れて
家を回ってる時にアンチが出てくると
引っかけさの絶対嫌だと思うんでちょっと
幸せすぎて今日はこらしめたいと思います
よしみんな頑張ろうぜ課金こらしめようぜ
今日はやりましょうよやろうやろうよし加
に嫌な思いさせるぞ
う
はいというわけでHIKAKINさん到着
されました
えてはい先に来ちゃってあそういう
ことおはようございますさんおはよう
ございますおです初めておにたというはい
お邪魔させていただきます今日はそして
あけましておめでとうございますご結婚お
めでとうごありがと
ドキし
てありがとうございますいやいや本当気で
聞いたのでマジで心臓とばかと思いました
というわけで親ぶようやく越させて
いただきました2
ハウスちょっと怪しいんだよねえいやいや
そんなそんな何もしないですよちょっと
怪しいんだよねすごいですねやっぱり
でしょそう去年はねでも思い切って借りて
よかったですねいやすごいなんか高さも
そうですけど横に広い感じがそうなんだよ
ね横幅がねあの一見やと思えないくらい幅
があとこ後ろすごいですよこれま進撃進撃
の巨人だからですね
おオールマリアですよもう超大型巨人が
来る感じのこれがあることによって
なかなかねプライバシーがあそっかそっか
そうそう
そうそうここでゲーム投映できるかパあ
そっかプロジェクターもいけるターいや
せっかくですねちょっと二のお家今回遊び
に来させていただいたということで僕も
あの4億円ハウスの主としてちょっと参考
にしたいなと思ってデザインとか色々見て
まりたいのでちょっとルームツアみたいな
感じでちょっとあの紹介していただいても
いいですかねいいですかありがとうござい
ますいろんな人来られて何回も紹介され
てると思うんですけどいすまじゃちょっと
お邪魔させてください任
やっ行きましょう行きましょういや木
かっこよ木がね主とかいるんだよええこう
いう自然の庭とかもすごいテンション
上がりまんそうそれがいいんだよだから庭
なかったら住んでないかもしんないねうん
うんうんうんあここが玄関ですねそうです
そうですそうですそうですげどどざします
邪魔させていただきます失礼し
ます
うわあ
すげえいらっしゃいませここは何ですか
もう早速ここはもうあのシューズ
クローゼットなんだけどとあ袋の
クローゼットはいはいはいはいそうそう
そうそうこういうあアウターとかですね
そう全然入れてないけどそうそうそうそう
あすげえこう
いうそうなですそうそうそうあとこっち
そうあのタこえぐいえぐいえぐいもう水の
がABCマートよりここですごいですよ
もう
そうここペットのあの
えどうした
どう
これはめ社長から聞いちゃったんですけど
あれ
HIKAKINマジでクリエイター思い
らしいですね
誰誰誰です誰ですか誰怖いよ誰怖かったよ
マジで誰です
か何これ誰すかカじゃないっすよでも
なんかあんまり親分のこと好き好きそう
じゃなかったっすねアンチが侵入してんの
かと思ったよいやそそううすねちょ
びっっくりしたマジでびっくりしたんだ
けど
俺怖いすねやってんなれだろ
なクリエーター思いですよいいいこと言っ
てくれさここれ
はこれはペットペットの
あのシャワーとかあの土で汚れた足を洗う
ていうあなるほどなるほどそ犬大型犬とか
買ってたら多分いいんだよねペットでこの
サイズそう俺が浴びようかなみたいなね
シャンプーけるしねみたいなうん確かに
確かに
すごいすごいよすごいっす
よありがとうございますどんどん行き
ましょう
[音楽]
かここ実はねこあ大丈夫かうわうわうわわ
おすごいすごいすごいここねあすごいよ
崩れちゃってんだよなこれちょっとあの僕
あの崩しちゃったりしたんですけど
トイレットペーパートイです
[音楽]
すげえ何閉めるの
分かった分かったはいはめカラーをあげる
よはいあスライムカラーだありがとう
ございますちょっといい香りがするんです
よこれあ本当だいやこれもなんかなんか
ホテルみたいでねこれなんか絵でも飾るの
かなみたいなよくわかんないそ確かに
なんか写真とか入れられそうですねそう
なんでもここなんかホテルを意識してる
らしいですねうんうんうんすごいちょっと
カメラで離れてみたら分かると思うんです
けどめくさこここのウェイがいいですよね
おしゃれわこういう壁もいいですねやっぱ
なんか新しい感じが好きでねうんやっぱ蓄
年数があんま行ってない感じがいいですよ
ねいつ頃このうって立ったんですかえ確か
ねでもまだ34年くらいうめっちゃ新しい
ぽいうんわ好きなんでねおおいいですねお
おこれこれはそうわ1000万の盾
1000万の盾だそうなんですよ
いよここに置いとくわかっこいいかっこ
いいよねこれねこれマジでまだ誰にも言っ
てないんですけどうんこれ落としちゃって
中のダイヤモンドぶっ壊れまし
たこの奥には何があるんですかくリビング
すげえこれがリビングこれがリビングこの
天井だがいいでしょいやたか
あれいやいい部屋ですねいあテレビとかも
大きいテレビも配電キで奮発してバーン
買ってでけえま初めでしても一軒やだから
分かるけどさ爆音で出してもさあんまり
この何ほらマンションで隣の部屋に
聞こえるとかないからはい迷惑考えなくて
いいのがねでかいですねいや
すげえ高級ホテルみたいな高級ホテルの
フロントみたいな
ね
ねあ音が違うめょ
いらっしゃいはいありがとうございます
これ金色のこういう光り方めっちゃいいな
そうなんかこれがあの玄関から見えるよう
に作ってあるらしくてあなるほどなるほど
そうなんかあのライトに導かれてこう来る
とみたいな感じらしいですえめっちゃいい
おしゃれあここがキッチンですかこ
キッチンですいやおしゃそう何もないです
い料理方が取りやすい確かに全面オープン
なのがねそうそうそうなんかキッチンは
ですけどここだけ白いのがすごい撮影向き
そうそうなんだよね思ったより黒いからね
かっこよくなっちゃうんうんうん
[音楽]
うんコーヒー飲んでんすよあいいす
ね物部対し味噌キあ味噌キ食べたいっすあ
だめだ今年食べれねえんだえだうわき入っ
てるからやっちゃってんじゃん最悪だ
スープだけのスープだけ
スと火薬だけど他の部屋も見してください
はいはいはいあこっちとか行ってみます
こっちはいはい
[音楽]
はい指示さてるこっち行ってみたいです
こっちはいうわ階段かっこよライトここ
なんかさYouTuber的にさスーパー
ボールとか落とせるよなみショート向けの
学ですね長いんですここがね回行き
ましょういやこのロング階段と照明がが
結構まになってるのがおしゃれそううわ
ここが服のない
結構待って何着いやだからいやここの家を
立てた人が超服が好きだったのかなうん
うんうん確かに靴の収納もちょっとすごい
ですもんねそうだねやっぱ服とか
ファッションが好きな方だったんですかね
うん僕が立てるなら多分クロゼットはもう
個人としますからねうんいや放題じゃない
ですこれいやさすがにね俺たまにしか買わ
ないからねうまんないすね一生ね多分も
こっちはちなみにこちお風呂ですお風呂
うわでけえジじんおジジだ
そうこれがね1回アブロやったんだけどね
すごかったんすよいやおしゃれだね失礼し
ます綺麗
でしょ上の照明好きね
めっちゃいいじゃないですかそうすよ失礼
します失礼しますテやなって庭が見えてん
のがいいんだよねここねいいなあだって
この高さでもまだ壁が高いから見えないん
だよ外がそう動画も撮りやすいですねあ
確かに映り込みがあんまりそう外別にあと
気になったのがそこもすごいですねそちら
のそうなんてつうんだ脱衣所的なところが
ねるみたいなそうなんですよ脱
[音楽]
このこれがねこれがねおわってなんてあっ
てはいここに手をすまさかまさかまさか
いやショッピングモールなそうですよ
まさか蛇口てなこうやんなくていいすこれ
すごいよなここもすごいな
可愛い小めっちゃ化粧水とか置きたい本当
は置くのかなぽいですねここにパパ
パパパそんなね1本とかしか持ってない
からあこれあれですすごいなんかこれ
ねうおびっくりした
うお
うあ俺ヒカキのそうゲームズの方よく見る
んですけどはいなんか毎回リアクションが
面白すぎるんですよありがとうござい
[音楽]
ますみんなし
たなんすか
ね全く意味がわかんないですそうこちらが
3回の3回行き
ましょう3回建てですか3回そうなんかね
なんだろう不思議な構造になっててねまで
も一応3回だけおそうジムですジム来まし
たもうケやめちゃったわあれやめちゃい
ましたもうちょっとマチになってたのにや
ちょっとよおかしくなるんだよね痛くなっ
ちゃうプうんそうそうそっから2週間とか
痛たくなるんで結構本当にえちょっとやっ
ていいですかいいすよこれが今ね
えっと50kgかマジっすか50kgはっ
てね親分行けます50てるよちょっとじゃ
スルしますいいすえ怖ですストッパーある
やばくなったらねガシャンて入れられるん
またいますそうんでやばくなっから助ける
はいよし行きますよはいどうぞ行きます
はい
50km
あ結構やばいちょちょっと低いとこいかけ
て
ギリギリ
やちょっとサウナ入りすぎっすね筋トレに
もちょっとサウナの時がね使ったいいです
ね
あこれこれですねそうそうそうそう
えあ理すごい俺これ逆に無理なんだよ体重
を持すぎ
[音楽]
てすごいなんか可愛いそうこれですね
いっていうね犬はいないんだけどねあそか
ペット用の入り口みたいな多分そのなん
だろ夏とかあの冬とか冷房とか暖房とか
炊いてここ寝室で閉め
てでもここだけスイスいってあペットが
生きしやすいようにだから多分大型県
やっぱ大型県買ってたのかなだか多分
うんうんなんかちょっとペット意識っぽい
ですねここがさ寝室ここが
寝室失礼しますあでも俺ここなか撮影屋と
かにしたくてあえてベッド置かないでいる
んだよねなんかすいダンススタジオみたい
なそうそうそうそうちょっとおしゃれだね
かやアパレルなんかね服屋さんぽいんだよ
ねうんデザインがそうでもここが一番広く
てなんだろ何でもできそうな部屋だからも
本当はここにソファー置いてもよかったん
だよなあこバーンとそうどうしようかなっ
ていう状態で半年く経っちゃった感じいや
すげえでもここっぽいですね撮影そう広さ
的には本当はこんくらい広いといいよなっ
ていうオレンジより部屋が多すぎて迷い
ますねどうしようってなっちゃうあ初めシ
結構もうぶち抜けてるもんねなんか
でっかい部屋がダンダンダンみたいな感じ
なんでそう3回だけか細かそうなのあの
コンビニがあったとこああそうですねね
あそこだけちょっとこちょっと熟地してる
んでねはいはいお家付きなので潜入するか
もしれないですね勝手にねうわ広トイレ4
つあるんでねここは何ですかここ物置き
ですね
[音楽]
ええうちの尿のやつが毎日毎日Hi
ヒカキ俺ことはほして
向く穴が立つんだ
よ
あご結婚おめでとうございますありがとう
ござい
ます大丈夫ですか怖かったすね大丈夫です
かおじさんの香りがしたちょっと最初入り
方がアンチっぽいからさぶあれはマジで
アンチすちょ親ぶがモテてるから奢っ
ちゃったアンチっすあれはさすが
にあんな年行ってるアンチの人いんのかな
はいやっぱアンチもだなアンチも色々い
ますから
ね別に言ってることはねいいことなんだよ
ね大学生とか中学生っぽい人もいたしああ
最初大学生中学生えおじさんじさん50代
中番ちょっと色々いますね
やっぱり次行きましょうかぶどうぞ行き
ましょうあここで下りになるんですねそう
なんすよなんかなんかなんつうんだろう
そうに2回2箇所から3階に行け
るっていうかなんか山みたいななんかなん
つんださそうなんだよ真ん中に3階がある
かっこいいここなんか結構そうここあのこ
仕事部屋にしよっかなとかうわ思ってる
なんか配信部屋とかにできそうそうなんか
床黒くてちょっとこうなんかっこいいから
ここ仕事部屋かなっていううんうんうん
なんかもう何人か人返そう
すベッドみたいになってまでもなんか多分
子供部屋うかそうですねな感じがしてるん
だよねいやいいな自分のスペースあったら
ねそうだよね子供は大喜びですよ
大丈夫ですか大丈夫ですね
はい隠れんぼしてるみていいいやあそして
おここね2台目見てこのソフ
HIKAKINさんといえばこのソファー
ですよ
[音楽]
もう
うわびっくりし
たおいけはい俺めっちゃ仕事頑張ってんの
になんで俺より金持ってんだ
よもう頑張ってる
から叶わねえよ
[音楽]
もう大丈夫すか大丈夫す
かどんな人が出てくんのか怖いよ怖いよ
ちょっとイケメンだったななんかホストっ
ぽかったすねかっこよかったなった気が出
ましたね親分の力
にというわけでHIKAKIN
[音楽]
さん実は
今回親分
の20億円ハウスの中
にアンチを送り込んで
おはいさマジかよアンチ送り込みしての中
ににネタバレしやがったぜはいただの
ルームツアーだけじゃなくてやっぱ親先
すごいじゃないですか家20バーンとかご
結婚バーンやっぱこういいことすごすぎて
1回こバーンてやろうと思ってちょっとや
なことしてきてんだよ
ちょっとずっとHIKAKINさんの家に
アチ送り込みましたちょっとも心配だもん
なそうですかあもうもういないのねどう
でしょうねまだいいんのかまだ
いい朝から仕込んでんのよでももう大体
アンチは見つけたと思うのではいでも
ルームツアーはもうぜひしていただきたい
そうでももうほとんどもうもうだいぶ
アンチいなくなったと思いますやっぱ
YouTube活動長いとね誰しも
やっぱりみんなが賛成というか応援される
わけでもないからいますよんね多少なりと
もそうねそうねでもねやっまあんちゃん
やめた方がいいっすよ本当にいつもさもう
字で慣れてくんじゃんうんうんうん慣れて
くるとさ今さこう初めてさなんかこうああ
いう反応されたことないからさ街であっ
たりし
てされたことないからちょっと怖かった
いややっぱそうですよね直接アンチにある
ことなんてないですからねないないない
ガチアンチだったからさでも言ってること
優しかったから良かったけどあれでひどい
こと言われたらちょっともうどうしようか
いや傷つけますよちょっといい人だった
からだった怖いないや怖いっすあここまた
下りになってますねここ下りになってます
そうですこっちかもうほとんどもう見
ちゃってるな俺多分
うんあおお見たいのがあります1個お確か
プールありましたよねありますうわ
すげえプールみたいすプール見てやっぱ
ここ積みたいと思ったからねいやでかいっ
すよねもう決めてちょっと見してください
プールだえもうここここわすげえ温水暖房
を聞きますどうぞありがとうございます
失礼します
すげえ知らねえ人が入っ
てる
こんにちは
あれあれちょっと待って
[音楽]
HIKAKIN
あれお前
さここの住所東京
都垂らす
ぞ
[音楽]
はいというわけでHIKAKINさんはい
ルムありがとうございましたいやめっちゃ
いい家でしたちょっと気づいてたかわから
ないんですけどぶのお家
にアンチぶんました最後の方まで何か意味
わかんなかったよただ親ぶ実は皆さん
アンチではないですあ本当ですかはい
アンチじゃないです言わせやがったなはい
全部仕込みました皆さんありがとうござい
ましあ笑顔になったあ良かった笑顔になっ
た怖かったまたでもねなんかほらもう
強がってくるじゃんYouTuberやっ
てるとあもう僕別にあのなんかねあのゴミ
とか言われても何も思わないとか思けどね
リアルでねああいう感じだとねちょっと
来るねやっぱねやっぱ直接怖かったよ皆
さん心苦しかったと思うんですけどごめん
なさいねありがとうございますめっちゃ
演技指導して先に演技指導してもうけど
やっぱ嫌な顔して嫌なこと言うと本当に
良くないと思ったんであの言葉だけはいい
こと言うんですけど表情だけはマジで嫌い
そうにしてくださいてて入念に仕込んだ
ステルスアンチでございます太り目の彼が
なかなかねやばかったですねやばい感が出
てましたあのネットと顔は見えないので
分かりにくいと思うんですけど直接言わ
れるとね傷つくこともあるのでそうですね
はい皆さんアンツとか誹謗中書は本当に
やめましょうそうですねいたずらでなんか
あのねいきなりあの訴えられるかもしれ
ないから本気をつけてください当気をつけ
ましょうじゃや楽しかったですそうねはい
いやいやい次は100人連れてきますやめ
てくださいね